ooh
[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm lien can I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting hey I was trying to like
cue you that this was gonna be more of a
sensual start yeah I didn't want to
follow you there yeah so the music
decided nights
I hope the music started sensual and
then like once Rhett didn't follow me
it's like it went away but not with a
record scratch the music is always the
same these are edit notes don't know
record scratch music has always been the
same so you can make it sensual in your
own mind like oh dress me I have and I'm
not talking to you I'm talking to you
oh your biscuits here trust me they have
you can make I believe that one of the
reasons that we picked the theme song
that we did pick for ear biscuits is
because you can make it say anything you
can make it sad you can make it happy
you can make a sexual note right this
can be anything literally go easier
sometimes when you're just sitting there
and there's a noise that starts
happening over and over again in a
rhythm like it might be a fan that's
getting caught or something like that
and then it kind of begins to make a
little rhythm and you think you got a
song on your head that it's maybe it's a
slow jam that started it could be an art
Kelly thought well before I should bring
our Kelly into it but it could be any
kind of thing that you want it to be you
know yeah I think that that that's
that's what your biscuits is all about
it's what you make it well that's not
really true and we know that we're gonna
be talking about relationships we ask
you challenge our advice giving prowess
with your most difficult romance
questions such a pretentious way to ask
a question well that's that's our mo
isn't it we like to think that we've got
great answers to every it was it was
tongue-in-cheek it was facetious I'm
sorry if you didn't interpret it that
way reading your own copy on the
internet we are going to
yeah get into some relationship mess I
won't be talking that way we're going
any point we're gonna stir it up and and
get the aromas eking out oh come on
and then we're gonna taste the soup baby
there will be no eking and there will be
no tasting getting choked up okay I'll
stop I think my throat problems coming
back we're just we're talking about oh
we're talking about relationship advice
is a tough word we're just gonna you
know give some we're gonna give our
perspective maybe that's helpful we're
just gonna chat we're not and give our
POV on the l UV am I gonna start I push
this out no need to pull it back in I'm
sure so let's just get into a question
man yeah yeah yeah yeah let's do that
Gina hair my boyfriend sometimes goes
days without showering how do I politely
tell him he smells like moldy swiss
without hurting his feelings well first
of all I mean if follow-up question is
is this just a is this is she being
sensational or does he really smell like
moldy swiss well it's a very specific
observation if he goes days without
showering and he's he's like the mean
average that's redundant of activity
he's probably gonna smell but everybody
smells like a different thing and if you
eat a lot of cheese let's just let's
let's just accept this question at face
value that yes he does like Jesus
because so this already stinks
is it okay so he's think it stinks but
then it tastes good does he taste good
that's that's the question guys your
your lips taste like Swiss but they are
but your body smells like Swiss so this
is a zero-sum game this is a problem I
will say that well I think if you go
days without showering that's the
problem
the
I don't know and then if you're dating a
person who goes days without showering
that is the second push our ring is a
modern day phenomenon I you know I know
I'm but then I also think it's a problem
that Jean is asking how do I politely
tell that is the real problem I I think
if you know don't need to be polite well
first of all I think this is a
foundation that I think we're of
perspective we're gonna bring to all of
these relationship questions and some of
them are gonna are gonna get a lot more
weighty than this first one I'll just go
ahead and and tell it's gonna get real
but even for this one I will say it
can't be a question of am I gonna say
something or not first of all you can't
live or be in a relationship with
somebody who stinks if or smells in
weight if you don't like them to and you
and secondly you have to be able to find
a way to talk about it and it's I don't
think polite ly is the right adjective
adverb I mean that you're looking for I
think it's effectively and lovingly have
the conversation another way to say what
you're getting at say it in another way
the foundation is communication eunuch
ation and you're asking this question
Gena as if you're talking about a
co-worker you know in terms of the way
that we see communication so like right
I might have an acquaintance or I might
have a co-worker or I might have you
know if you if you're in school you
might have a classmate that has a
problem with their hygiene and you you
would ask the question how do I politely
address this how do I politely address
the situation with somebody that I don't
know well enough to just talk to them
about it openly but when you're in the
relationship with somebody hurting his
feelings you're it's beyond you want to
be beyond that place so I don't know
maybe this is a very new relationship
and so but if this is if this
relationship is a serious dating
relationship and this is beyond like I
actually just says series serious and
then Siri came up go ahead I'm listening
she says Siri what do you think about
this answer about a
know your mind it was your point my
point was is that maker stop listening
quit listening Siri Kali is that you
should be beyond this and in the
relationship I'm assuming that this is a
serious dating relationship and you have
to fight there's a deeper problem here
you got to get to a place where you can
have communication where this kind of
stuff is being addressed like yeah you
see if I smell my wife smells right what
she doesn't but if she did we all do at
some point yeah yeah or your breath
stinks or yeah I let her know and she
lets me know and it's in it's it's just
part of it it's part of the contract
the honesty contract and so you just get
two things a lot more quickly if you're
concerned about hurting your partner's
feelings when it comes to them not
showering for three days and you telling
them that they stink then you're in for
a world of challenges in conducting your
relationship when there are like the
real stuff hits the fan when it really
stinks and you've got and you're gonna
hurt their feelings
now well I mean when Christie tells me
man your your breath stinks or did you
eat garlic for lunch because you're like
reeking yeah okay if if if the wrong
people are in the room when she says
that and she says it in the wrong way
then it might hurt my feelings a little
bit
but I cannot have a relationship where
the person that I trust and love the
most can't tell me when I am yeah when I
don't realize I'm doing something
offensive right that's the that's the
that's the bedrock of a relationship you
got to look out for each other so I
think to answer your question that's how
you approach it yeah it's not a
complaint that like hang you stink I
don't like how you smell but it's like
hey I'm looking out for you we are a
team we got to make sure neither one of
us stinks right and you're the one who
does and it probably to do with the fact
that you don't shower enough yeah when
halitosis is the biggest offender here
let me just bring that into it we'll
move on to another question I don't take
so much time on this one but what
happens when one of the one of the
people in the relationship has halitosis
and it's not addressed by the person who
obviously smells that two things happen
first thing that happens is yes it
settles in it
Thaksin and then 20 years down the road
there's just you've learned to live with
it you're one of those people that when
you open your mouth at a grocery store
in aisle next to you I can tell the
cereal box is melt somebody with
halitosis is opening their mouth could
be yawning could be talking linking our
super hyper sensitive to it and it was
really angry and knowing level but
because it's so easily addressed in 99%
of the cases by a partner but the
partner is the one who has to address it
right don't let this be perpetuated
you're creating eyes you're creating a
prophetess ayat I was at a freaking
restaurant recently enjoying time with
my family and there was a husband and
wife and it's usually dudes let me just
go ahead and say dudes got bad breath
most of the time I know something about
what's happening in her body something
we're not talking about something you
eat we're talking about something that's
living there and dude sits down with his
wife and like 15 seconds into him
sitting now apparently he opened his
mouth it was rifted over to your family
and Jesse and I immediately made eye
contact and just started shaking our
heads and well he's got it and it's a
specific bacteria it's prevalent all
across the world and you know who's you
know who's at fault the person dining
with him and not saying a person who's
closest who's too in denial how the heck
are you supposed to say something how a
waiter can't say anything catch it early
get [ __ ] often be honest attack the
stink at the heart and you know what
fart in a relationship early just get it
out there I know people who have gone
many many years and have not farted in
front of each other and then there's
there's another hang-up where people
don't like to like your your I've been
in your your bathroom at home now my
bathroom in my home the toilet is
sequest
it's a cool secluded I love it isolate
Western toilet it's it's it's almost
laws it but every other house I've ever
lived in it was just out in the open and
in your house it's out in the open
I'm fixing it I'm building a cardboard
no no but I think that this is actually
great because I mean there's gotta be
times when you're taking a dump and
Chrissy's brushing her teeth
right I mean this
no because I use the I go downstairs and
use the guest bathroom for that well
you're not backing at my point what I'm
saying is is that now I can respect
somebody who's like we want to keep the
romance alive I've got close friend I'm
not saying you take it to take a turn
drop in front of your spouse or your
lovely okay maybe I've taken it too far
but you got to go too far to know when
to come back from it okay so don't
necessarily take dumps in front of each
other you wouldn't follow me into
talking like this but you expect me to
follow you into that know my wife
Christie mm-hmm you know we're ordering
at a restaurant and if it I'm like I I
hear her order and then I'm right now
that has a marinara in it you know that
makes you burp a lot
I'm like I don't want a narrow marinara
makes her burp specifically like and so
then the rest of the night she's doing
that thing Merce like like it oh Sh it's
like she doesn't like bar yeah you get
in the car and then you then you just
smell it
well it's not even the smell of the
thing I can't it is for me well this
much this smells great but I honestly
don't smell it as much as it just annoys
me when it's is like she does that like
trying to show to not exude a burp I
caught the chili dog burp well we call
it the the coach royal because our grade
school coach would always like under his
breath anyway thought by stopping
talking hang on he was hiding it like
his cheek we know how it's happening
coach we see that you're burping and
it's like wallowing but it's like it's
acid reflux is the problem or something
I think that's what's happening with my
and I'm like don't acid reflect a
marinara Alfredo but I you know what we
have an open honest conversation about
it nobody's feelings are hurt and we
both get a little annoyed but I mean
what what is love if you're not annoyed
it's part I mean that is a sign that
you're truly will get it we won't live
into there's another one well we're like
13 minutes in so I do want to stop for a
second they sell something take a short
break
okay sure and let you know that you can
get these wonderful ear biscuits mason
jars
not really mason jars the Masons don't
use them it's a myth it's made out of
biscuit batter hardened in the heart of
Mordor no we probably can't say that not
associated with Lord of the Rings
trademark anyway you can get one that
signed maybe yeah mythical dot store and
you order one of these and there are
limited supplies we're not gonna keep
these forever there's a handful left and
some of that handful are signed by us
and the only way to get one is just go
buy one and then maybe you'll get a
signed one it's like the lottery but
there's no money given to you you spend
money so it's not like the lottery but I
mean it's cool
because we may have actually that is
exactly like the lottery you spend money
and you don't win anything
but you are guaranteed to get something
unlike the lottery you can drink out of
it if it's signed you can drink out of
it and just don't put it in the
dishwasher because it will come off
mythical dot store Kaley Cathleen
Bentley submitted to us an ex of mine
which had it and she did not submit to
us she just submitted to us this
question yeah an ex of an ex of mine had
an incredible personality amazing taste
in music a great sense of style we had
the same political views and even our
dreams for the future were pretty much
aligned I'm sensing a but here no big a
hole but the only negative was that he
had a pretty insane amount of facial
hair facial hair it would get in the way
of our kisses constantly because it
essentially grew over his lips I'm not
kidding when I say this thing had a mind
of its own what would have been a polite
way polite again what would have been a
polite way of offering to help trim it
or keep it clean if only for the benefit
of other women hashtag ear biscuits I
mean obviously I take personal offense
at this we actually made it we made a
video about kissing and having a beer
sponsored by Gillette yeah and it was it
was me shaving my face and saying that I
was a superior kisser because of it now
how to kill a beard I think is what I
changed the name to Kayleigh here's what
I will say
it may be true that it's more fun to
kiss a man without a beard but it is not
more fun to look at this man without a
beard so I'm a lot less kissable without
this beard because I look like an alien
that was abandoned on another planet on
another planet really not his home
planet
oh hey Lia not this planet so to two
things an alien did not make it to one
of the human race I got and then
abandoned by whatever race he is a part
of so it's better to be kissed and have
a compromising experience than to not
entice someone to kiss you at all but I
was just saying that is a prelude
because my real answer to the question
is that I think that the sensation that
you feel when you kiss a bearded person
is something that you actually adjust to
relatively quickly like if you think
that is gross are you speaking from what
jesse has told you yes okay it's the
kind of thing that if you've never
kissed a bearded person I assume that
you you notice and you experience the
beard and you may have a negative
experience with the beard but I think
that experience I mean I think that get
multiple kisses eventually it's just
like it's just part of their face but
you says that it grows over the lips and
I have seen guys with that now and I
ain't actually grew over his land I will
say that I do I trim you've got it
across right above the lips I do that
for my own benefit because if I don't do
that then when I'm eating it pushes hair
into my mouth which I hate but I think
that this is just I think you could have
had a great relationship if you had it
just committed to the beard
however again with what you were getting
at this whole how do I politely suggest
if you didn't like the beard and it was
a it was a deal-breaker for you
and he wouldn't look like an alien
without his beard then you should have
just don't worry about being polite if
it's part of the relationship and
there's all this stuff that I'm not
saying being a jerk about it yeah I just
think this is easy I mean if you tell a
guy that you're dating dude I really
desire to kiss you and have an enjoyable
experience while we're doing that but I
kept but I I need you to I need you to
trim back the hedge make making me a
target like I can't even tell that you
have a mouth right now I don't even know
yeah I don't even know where to begin if
you say that like I'm very motivated to
kiss you this is not an ultimatum but
this it I am just saying honestly this
will make it a better experience for
both of us
I guarantee you that thing will be [ __ ]
yeah yeah if it's that big of a priority
then you just got to address it and they
got to deal with it and if they end up
looking crazy after they get rid of it
then maybe you'll change your mind I
can't imagine having the moustache just
go straight across the mouth that seems
crazy to me well a lot of some people
are willing to grow it so far that they
then push it to the so [ __ ] yeah gonna
step aside you got again you gotta work
as team it sounds like a bad beard
management situation right really is
what it boils down to so far it seems
like these these women got a swoop in
and help their men with some just basic
hygiene let's have a question that
should never be apologized all right
Timothy Coupland it all seriously is
there a question mark at the end of his
last name that's weird I've never I've
never never seen that in all seriousness
studies show that after around 3 to 6
months the initial hormones that make
you crazy in love wear off and in fact
your body grows tired of the other
person's pheromones what should a person
do to keep a relationship going during
this time three to six months you say
you fall out of that like infatuation
level of love well let's just start by
saying I don't know if the science is I
you may be right about this I have not
researched this particular thing I don't
know if the specific thing that you're
saying about the pheromones is true but
I do know that's the concept of the
crazy and love initial sparks crazy
about each other in the first few
getting to know each other wears off
that is a that is a truth all
relationships so it's really a quick
it's a great test of when that
inevitably happens does something more
enticing in a different way replace it
you know it's a different kind of love I
think you know we've may I will have
been married to Christie for 18 years
well and then and then for you in June
will be 17 June will be 17 years of
marriage and then you add a couple of
years of dating so this anniversary I
mean this by the end of this year it'll
be 20 years of us being in like a
committed relationship so I have a hard
time thinking back to like when when
things started to shift you know but I
certainly know that you don't make it
years much less decades just based on
just feelings I mean it you know it's
it's you start to I mean it's it's
commitment you start to act within the
within the confines confines not the
right word within the within the a
relationship structure that it doesn't
have a question mark on the end of it
you know where it's hey we are we are in
this together we're now we're we're
fully committed
it's not about questioning that so I it
is a really important decision you know
to to make a commitment whether that's
in marriage or you know just
conversationally I guess you know
wherever you're at in your relationship
but you've got to I lost my train of
thought what was I saying can I hop on
the train hop on yeah
did you take the train is that what
happened exactly is a new technique I'm
sorry I read a wiki how it works why
don't you get what I was saying I told
didn't exist let's get the train of
thought I think we're on the same train
incidentally yeah did this initial
infatuation that is you know the reason
that you fall in love it's there for a
very particular reason right it's like
and we'll get into this in a little bit
you know I think that if you just if you
just follow your raw natural desires
apart from any kind of social contract
or obligations or like what's ultimately
best for you your family in the world
you're gonna be a serial cheater
a person who's is you know you ain't a
serial monogamist whatever whatever the
flavor of the month is that's what
you're kind of naturally going to
gravitate towards because that initial
rush its physiological this is not
that's happening to you why don't you
just say serial monogamist that confused
me well because some people are serial
cheaters and then some people are serial
monogamist meaning they go for they're
still there with one person at a time
but they they run out of steam with a
person and they go to the next one not
necessarily you know being unfaithful to
the person they're with but it's the
same kind of concept it's like I've got
to have something new like that kind of
releases those you know gets that part
of my brain active and almost like a
drug and the falling in love it but if
that's what you're expecting from a
relationship all I will say having been
married almost 17 years in 18 years here
is that it does come in cycles so I
think that first of all it's not like
well there's this initial incredible
energy that starts the relationship and
then you know three to six months in
you're just cold and you don't want to
be with a person and you just you're
just you stick with it well now that's
not what we're saying at all no if you
have the mentality that link was
describing that's based on commitment
and your your your committed to
continuing to discover each other and
know each other and and Kindle things
it's gonna come in waves and and that's
that's what I've got
commitment is separate from the waves
and I
say my experience is that a commitment
between Christy and I opened up a world
of possibilities for us to then you know
experience relationship on another level
that if if there's this constant be it
ever so small threat or question mark in
our relationship that maybe this isn't
going to work out or maybe maybe she's
not 100% committed or I'm not 100% into
this and you know what if you take that
off the table it it just opens up a
world of trust so then you can
experience everything that life throws
at you and that relationships and being
the closest to somebody else on earth to
have somebody in your inner circle like
so close to you that it's like they
become part of you is something that I
just can't imagine that happening if you
have question marks so once you so for
us having that commitment allowed us to
then whether it's not even whether like
the the the rough patches in the
relationship which are I think are
guaranteed to come and again and again
and it you know some because the love
the nature of the love and you can grow
I mean those are beautiful moments I'm
saying even rough patches become
beautiful moments like when when when
when life hits you hard and you have
somebody that you're going through it
with it can be a very beautiful thing if
you're not constantly questioning and I
think that the the the rush that you get
from love that's been around for over a
decade there are moments that are even
stronger and more significant than the
initial attraction a lot of times we
talk about how we didn't have any idea
what we were doing we were young we got
lucky honestly both of us got very lucky
because a lot of people
who get married at the age that we got
married at and then changed because we
have changed I was 21 when I got married
yeah I turned 22 the Laree the week
after and and I was 23 and as a 40 year
old I am a very different person than I
was at 23 my wife is a very different
person than she was at 1 1919 when we
got married and a lot of people don't
make it past those significant changes
like in your late 20s there's a there's
big life changes in your early 30s big
mid-thirties there's these big changes
that happen in most people's lives
mm-hmm
we just got lucky that but there was a
luck factor to it I do believe because
we do love each other if we do like each
other like we do generally like each
other we're not tolerating each other
but I think the moments that we've had
you know in the past 10 years I've been
much more ultimately much more intense
when it comes to romance than they were
in the very early stages I also think
that I never believed in like a soul
like is this soul mate what you call the
person that like the one person you were
like destined to be with well which is I
mean I'll ask this question as you get
into this be okay Dustin Israel says
short and simple I want to know how you
guys would define true love as in the
kind you have for your own wives what
got you there how did you know that this
is it not that you can always put a real
definition to the idea but as an avid
ear biscuits but as an avid ear biscuit
here I'm curious to see where you two
take this conversation so what's true
love saying you don't believe in
soulmates well no I think that I that's
just what I've always thought like I
always believed that you know human
beings being deeply flawed it's
guaranteed that when you're in such a
close-knit relationship with somebody
when you partner up that things are you
know there's all those flaws are gonna
it's gonna be difficult and it's so
that's the first thing I've always
believed is that
you is you're not gonna find the perfect
person that there's never gonna be any
problems like it's just guarantees that
person doesn't have any ingredient the
piates are flawed people's the perfect
person doesn't exist the perfect match
for you
doesn't exist because the only perfect
match for you is yourself and then you
know what I'm saying and which could be
really horrible so I you know I think
giving bro no I'm not saying another
person who is exactly yourself I'm just
saying the only person you're ever gonna
get along with is your own mind oh yeah
I know you're saying that even then you
can't even I'm saying that might be that
might be a lot worse than giving
yourself over to jail yeah you're loving
yourself then allowing another flawed
person so closely intertwined into your
life that they make you a better person
and you make them a better person all
right so in believing that I think
that's what made me start believing that
there's no one that's perfect so
therefore there's no one person that I'm
looking for as much as for me I you know
you find yourself being very attracted
and loving somebody and then you know
it's a combination of that and then
compatibility and income and commitment
like I mean being a line in terms of the
things that you want for yourself from a
partner and in life I mean there's a lot
there's a lot of emotional but also
practical aspects to it that I just
don't think it's and I think it's you
know you being aligned enough to know
that like we're it makes it can work for
on paper for us to be partners well yeah
I think it's again we're not trying to
take the romance out of this thing but I
think it's a lot more practical than
anyone ever really wants to believe it's
not the word taking romance out of its
that romance checks itself out and then
you have to work to bring it back in
well well took to get back to the
soulmate thing and then the address this
question how you know you're supposed to
be with somebody
I think that just the concept of there
being one person that has been selected
for you by some cosmic force it's a
beautiful idea but the the reality seems
to be that it's much more practical than
that you met somebody at a time when you
were available you were in a life stage
where you were ready to get into a
serious relationship and they they
checked some boxes of physical
attraction and common interest and and
then next thing you know you find
yourself married and I think that
there's a very practical side to it and
it doesn't mean that it's not love but I
think that the love comes in in that
commitment that kind of surpasses the
because what happens is going back to
that previous question is like you're
also going to find there's going to be
somebody else along along the lines that
you meet and you're like well I I'm
attracted to them and I have I have
common interest with them it's like well
maybe that I should be with them instead
of the person that I'm with I mean that
happens in relationships all the time
but what you don't realize is that if it
was she was on the other foot and you
were with the person that you think you
should be with and you met the person
that you're with now you probably had
the same exact thought about them and I
I'd you know I do feel like I should
jump in here I think we I there's
certainly a balancing perspective for
somebody who's been through a divorce or
had been in a really committed
relationship and then there was a really
catastrophic breakup and then on the
other side of that you haven't
experienced true love or found another
partner you know it's a so I hope I do
want to acknowledge that you and I we we
have basically the same experience so I
got lucky like that's why I said I don't
I don't I want to be very clear to say
that I don't think well I'm still with
my wife because I understand commitment
a big part of it is that Jesse and I
have realized as we've gotten older that
we actually like each other even as
we've changed we still like each other
and that has made the ability to stay
committed easier because I think there
are people who go through fundamental
changes
personality or worldview and then they
cannot be compatible in a way we live
with our life situation and some people
stick it out and they get through that
and some people decide you know what
we've collectively decided that we both
want different lives and I respect that
decision so I'm not saying that this
means you can't make those decisions so
I completely agree with you and and but
we both got lucky and the fact that it
still is still working out yeah I think
to summarize that we in no way want the
perspective that we're giving to be
interpreted as moral advice you know
we're giving her a judgment of some kind
or any judgment just giving you our
perspective you know I mean my dad I'm
I've been married a lot of times yeah my
mom's been married three times my dad's
been married five times you know and
it's it's it's something that I've
learned too
I think I used to try to I I judged that
as a kid or like as a newlywed you know
and that wasn't it wasn't fair so that's
the last thing I want to do - any - you
listening yeah so it's really just the
individual relationship that you're in
right now if you if there if you have if
you love each other and you are
compatible then just know that the
romance is going to is going to come and
go and the commitment has to if you're
going to say together the commitment has
to to supersede it okay let's move on to
a different subject from Melissa Eber
heart shouldn't my husband your age 40
ooh thanks and I not 40 come on Melissa
that's like me give in to the baby
pressure neither of us have kiddos
though thought I should ask some
brilliant
okay now you're on a good side forty
year olds if they would ever consider I
am NOT 40 dad hood starting at this age
and maybe I can convince him one way or
another so we quit going back and forth
so she wants to have a baby she's almost
40 and there are over
forty husband doesn't seem to be she
doesn't know she didn't she did not say
she wants to have a baby
she says she died given to the baby
pressure so she's probably got relatives
they just don't know what they want to
do and they're probably having important
conversations to me but then she said
the word convinced that's what gets me
know maybe I can convince him one way or
another
Oh so we quit going back and forth sorry
he just doesn't have his mind made up
and she apparently doesn't either and
there's a question that we wanted to
lump in with this one because we think
we can answer them together NAT who uh
wife ha ha ha that's what I said I'm
just saying it because I like the way it
sounds
poor ok you done
yeah I'll say it a few more times but go
ahead who-whoa wife and I are expecting
our first child in June up I've already
done it she is worried that this marks
the end of all things romantic dates etc
as parents and husbands yourselves any
pro advice again we are not pros but we
are we are brilliant 40 year old
husbands and parents oh man yeah well
the the having kids at 40 plus is a
specific thing but yeah let's not
because the the LA let's just assume
these people are on the Los Angeles
timeline one of the things I'm guessing
that's a specific question it it is but
I think that having been out here and
realizing that we are the very very odd
case that has you know you've got a high
schooler and I've got somebody's about
to be a high schooler and like out here
people don't start their families until
they're in their late 30s or 40s so this
is actually not that unusual at least
out here yeah so I don't want to get
into the age necessarily but because
we're actually we've been talking to
some friends of ours who have been
asking the question like they're friends
with us and a lot of other people who
have kids and they're just like should
we have kids you know and we've been
having this conversation
pretty candidly you got something I'm
afraid you're afraid to say it I'm
afraid to say well let me know I don't
have anything I'm afraid to say I'm just
to try to you know giving people advice
about if they should have a baby or no
but you shouldn't give any specific let
me just premise this but just do it just
have a baby let me just say that blame
us you will hate us if so let's just do
that if we did give the advice to have a
baby this may be a good thing then they
could they could blame us and be and
direct all their anger at us instead of
each other it's like you're the one who
convinced Mooji
that we should start having kids they
can they can direct it all towards rhett
and Link and then they can be a team
what about the child
okay well how's he gonna get out of it
what I'm just saying in the in the
moments when you're feeling like this is
freaking difficult which let's say it's
half the time the other half of the time
they're super grateful that they have
kids I mean you're gonna have both of
those times and in the time and you're
like man this is a big mistake it's like
why did I try to hike Everest and you're
already up there so it's like you're
almost up there so it's like you can't
come down now you're in it well you hate
us not each other well so I'm saying go
for it and blame us later
let me just premise this by saying that
I think that children are wonderful and
I think that I think that our society is
is ultimately built on the family unit
and so I think that healthy families
intact families with committed parents
who are committed to each other and
their kids is has been for thousands of
years the kind of glue the whole society
together you know III truly believe that
in it because you get Amin you get the
next generations got to come from
somewhere and if they're raised in home
stable homes it they're going to they're
going to do better right so but that
doesn't mean that everybody needs to be
a part of that movement and then there's
interest
things happening in different cultures
like you know typically the way that
this goes is you've got the more
educated people get the more developed
countries get the less children they
have and then you get into situations
like Japan where nobody's getting
married and having kids and now they're
getting this age population and they
want people to immigrate and they want
people to come and have kids because
just the way the whole system works and
then typically in developing countries
people are having lots of kids and
they're kind of driving their economy
and you know there's it's very complex
but for just the individual person and
the people asking the question and sort
of the thing that we've been talking
about with our friends is that you just
have to know like we didn't know we were
on a very different path we were on the
path that was graduate from college get
married have have kids and that is a
good job that typically is like it's
like southern United States Midwestern
United States like there's some pockets
of the country where that's kind of a
path that people go on like it may be
weird that I've got a 13 year old kid
but if I go back to North Carolina
everybody my age has a 13 year old kid
it is weird here but it's not as unusual
here so if you if you already have
established a life in kind of the people
that we know travel all the time they've
been to all seven continents they went
to seven continents in one year and
they're now there were seven they're all
over the place they're constantly doing
things and they have both all the way my
dad's only been married four times yeah
I thought about correcting you but then
I was like he probably knows better than
I know I thought it was in there's seven
continents so I got both those right now
got it I just told them I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna tell you whether you have
kids or not I just wanna let you know
that you you have children you won't go
to seven continents in one year so you
just need to understand that and you may
be like well we've already been to seven
continents in one year we've done that
and now we're ready for this different
adventure right so that so so NAT puah
saying she's expecting in June is this
the end of all things romantic
well Rhett saying this is the end of
visiting all seven continents definitely
and until for a long time but this is
also probably the end of one of you and
they can retire they can the kids will
be out of the house
depend on how old they are and then they
can visit all seven cotton well they
won't but it's also it's not just about
travel it's also about career you know
in our situation our wives made a
sacrifice to be the ones who spent the
majority of their time with the children
and just now that our kids are in school
and getting older they're beginning to
think about their careers huge sacrifice
and you know and not typically
historically that burden has fallen more
to two women than men that's changing a
little bit but you also have to think
about that because if you both have
something that's going to take a bunch
of your time you both got these big
dreams and these big desires you got it
you just got to know that something is
going to change monumentally and if you
both aren't on the same page about that
bringing a child into that it's probably
not a great guy I got two things first
of all so to your specific question does
this mark the end of all things romantic
yes for for at least a year I mean
you're gonna or until you can get a good
babysitter you got it you gotta find a
good babysitter and then you got to be
committed to paying that babysitter and
you can take you can win these couples
you can't be one of these couples who
doesn't it doesn't let the kids stay
with the babies it's like we have a kid
or grandmas of the baby or aunt I say
pawn that baby off on somebody as soon
as it is just it can live on its own for
anybody I mean anybody passing by on a
train know someone you trust with but
you got to be committed to that if you
have any hope of ever recapturing the
romance because it's gonna be gone for a
while don't let it be gone forever
you're at a crucial point poulos get
that babysitter but in and I'm not
volunteering second thing back to the
back to the previous question about the
should we can can we convince can I
convince him one way or the other so we
can quit going back and forth I'm gonna
give some specific
vice you tell me if you disagree or this
is if it's dangerous any caveats Melissa
and your hubby
you should earmark a certain amount of
time I'm talking about days to weeks
with a starting point and an end point
when where you are not going to discuss
it but you are going to you give each it
you give yourselves and the other person
the assignment to reflect and go on
whatever a Vision Quest means to you to
make a decision for right now are you
talking about ayahuasca I'm no I'm
talking about whatever that means for
you because I don't think you should
advise that I'm not that's an individual
sizing that I don't know I don't even
know how to spell that
it starts with an eye probably I just
don't think it's healthy for you to try
to convince her influence each other or
even verbally process it cos øx with na
I get the impression that you've done
that a lot so I'm doing like palm
reading here I'm consents that no I'm
not and then I think you should you
should come back with an answer
and then you should three two one say
your answer and the question should be
specific like so for the next six months
are we going to like let's make a
decision now for the next X amount of
time I'm gonna say six months before we
do we to start pick up this decision
again to maybe have children I think
that's a three to one like we do on GMM
and you say your answer yes or no and if
you both say the same thing then you do
it if you either yes or no you just
start having trying to have a baby or
not
and then if if you disagree you got to
wait is this is not the type of thing
that you can convince the other person
over say well if you feel that strongly
of course this is coming from somebody
that our third child we decided to you
know start trying to have who ended up
being Lando the conversation was
well I'll participate in in trying to
make a third baby if I get to name the
baby if it's a boy like that was
literally the negotiation but you
already had to so it wasn't like it
wasn't the decision to break the seal
and have children right so a third yeah
by the time we get to three it can just
come down to like frivolous negotiation
or something like who gets to name the
child right I get to name it we can make
it I don't think so I don't
altom Utley think your advice is bad I
mean another way to say it is you know
you could have a you could have say
we're gonna set a date by which we maybe
you have a summit maybe you just say
we're gonna take a day we're gonna go
somewhere and the focus of our
conversation or interaction especially
if you don't feel like there's one
person who would manipulate the other
and we're just gonna make a decision
together or you know what you just do
ayahuasca duh that's a joke
Shannon urban how do I get my hubby to
rinse the caked on peanut butter off his
spoons before putting them in the
dishwasher yes peanut butter is the
nectar of the Gods but it turns into the
devil's shoe gum once it's been sitting
in the sink a few hours these are the
conflicts upon which the foundations of
partnerships are eroded it's the little
things excuse me let me spend the next
30 seconds clearing my throat
ah yeah hua PO hua I'm just looking for
an opportunity to say that name again
hua pua it's exactly what you would
think it's spelled like I didn't oh I
thought it would be spelled with two O's
in an a it's whether you I frequently
sink my spoon into the delicious brown
nectar of peanut butter is this a
euphemism are you talking about peanut
butter and then and you know what when
I'm done with that spoon there's not a
there's not a remnant of peanut butter
you're not normal though because that's
I mean
it is a pet peeve of mine it's wasteful
you're in it and it creates these
problems and and you know what I think
that Chrissy and I you know you talk
about being lucky things that you
couldn't understand but I think one of
the keys to our compatibility is is how
we both like and maybe this is because
our skills and our faults line up in
this way but we're so compatible when it
comes to like keep in a house like
keeping spoons like we would both be
annoyed by those things where it's like
shared space type stuff like everything
needs a place and let's organize stuff
and let's use the dishwasher in this way
like we we're very compatible I think it
doesn't have been a being a real key to
our relationship and that we're
compatible in that way because we both
care so much about something that if the
other person didn't it would drive us
nuts so I really feel for you that he's
putting these tainted uncleaned peanut
buttered spoons in the in the dishwasher
and it sounds so scandalous man that's
that's tough man well I think I think it
I could be grounds for a kiss I think it
can lead to divorce well it could lead
to divorce I don't think it's grounds
for divorce no it's not I have the a
different perspective which i think is
interesting in light of what you just
said I don't know how to fix it
for it for you I wish I could because I
it's interesting because Jesse and I are
not on the same page when it comes to
the way that we approach quote keeping a
house as you said but my level of
concern about it is very very low so
first of all like Jesse's an incredible
designer our home is amazing it's like
we get compliments all compliments on it
all the time and I'm like it's her she's
the one she makes all these decisions
this looks great because of her I like
what you've done with the peanut butter
spoon in the sink and and it's in its
it's clean and it's
beautiful but there's a few drawers you
probably shouldn't open you know what
I'm saying and I I assume that every
drawer the Neil Neil house is worth
opening and useful and organized and you
probably have like organizers and that
kind of when people come over we ask
them to open the drawer open a drawer I
dare you just fishing for compliments
and so but that we've got closets and
doors that are hiding things and have
been hiding them for a very long time
you shall not pass and interestingly I
don't that's not what I would do and but
I think the fact that I have a high
tolerance level for it so it's like I
would not do this in the drawer but I'm
not gonna open a source of content but
I'm not gonna open this drawer and let
it really get my goat and so therefore
working paddock we're totally different
than you guys but but compatible and if
I felt the way that you feel about it
then it was either I would have had to
have changed or she would have had to
have changed right right but this
specific issue with the peanut butter
spoons is very very real in my family
with my children because I was just
telling somebody the other day we go
through to full size large peanut
butters a week in my home Wow my kids
eat so much peanut butter it is and I do
too and soda on the spoon we put it on a
lot of things you know I don't talk
about how much I love peanut butter a
lot of times because you know it's kind
of your thing from a brand stamp can
only be my thing but I probably eat more
than you do
what you that's not you eat more of
every night probably eat more peanut
butter like I have a peanut butter spoon
you still do the peanut butter spoon in
there talking milk every night not every
night I have peanut butter spoons all
the time and my kids have them all the
time and they take them and they and
they eat them and they don't get it
completely clean and they throw it in
the sink well different times that's why
you go through so much peanut butter cuz
they don't really like the spoon I'm not
arguing with you I lick it's clean I I
don't I don't I lick it clean and they
throw it in this thing in the sink and
sometimes I'll go and they'll be like
seven and we only have four people in
our and then it'll have a little water
on it from where the water has gotten
down into the spoon
I can't stand and it lightens the color
the peanut butter but it doesn't do
anything to it so you sit there and when
you wash it you've got to use your thumb
to get it out yeah well Shannon that's
that's wrong that that is so
inconsiderate make them use their own
thumb I think you got to wash it you got
oh they got a washer on I think you got
to rub their nose I think you got two
choices Shannon you rub you kids nose in
it
tell me what you've done before you tell
her what to do well as if you can't [ __ ]
me problem I'm gonna give you two
options option 1 is don't fix the
problem fix let it not be a problem well
someone has to clean the spoons you're
saying don't complain about it we don't
have to hand clean yeah you just take
care of it and you just do it but option
2 is you take those spoons and you find
a place in their bed that's his a place
that now and go bed and just a place
like it's Godfather horse like maybe the
passenger seat of his car you just take
a plate and you put all the peanut
butter spoons on the plate and you just
set it in his car on the passenger seat
passive-aggression yeah I just say all
right you want to you you can take care
of these this is what you want to do you
can take care of these I mean no III
don't I mean there's got to be way to
not be so passive passive aggressive but
I think or you just talk about it that's
no fun no I I think he he does have to
wash his own spoons like if you you know
like you know a kid doesn't wipe their
own butt until you stop wiping it well
no there was a few months there with
nobody's wife and shepherds but yeah
there's sometimes there's a gap what do
you mean a gap what are you talking
about I'm saying sometimes there's a gap
between when you stop and they start oh
there's a couple of months maybe a
couple of weeks where there just does
just poop on the butt so I mean whooping
the gap I'm just saying what you said
sound like a great point but I'm just
saying there's exceptions and I'm
familiar with one what are we going to
do it's gonna mean I think we should
pick the best question to end on okay
it's a little weird so let's in with
that one
Joseph Allen first off longtime listener
first-time caller
oh thank you for calling what's your
question Joseph
second my friends move in with me and it
has really put a cramp friends plural my
friends moved in with me okay I sound
like there's multiples and it has really
put a cramp in my wife and I as romantic
styles if you catch my drift what do we
do so he's married to a wife and they
have romantic styles but now he's got
friends living there this is this is uh
this is trouble this is not very very
troublesome and you want to have your
romantic stylings liaisons you might
call them well I've got I've got three
friends who live in my house my children
and I still find a way to have romantic
stylings and they have little to no clue
about what's going on yeah but you know
they each have I have my own bedroom yep
maybe they share a wall you don't share
a wall you you're on a totally different
floor that's right for your kids that's
right I'm on I'm across the hall so I
don't share a wall but for it what I'll
share well it's just soon they share a
wall but for adult friends I mean you
shouldn't have to you shouldn't have to
tiptoe around in your own house to do
naturally human partnership activities
well some team building exercises you
know I think he said romantic stylings I
mean romantic skies
yes he said romantic styles maybe he's
got different different styles I know a
couple but so anyway I think let's just
assume that there is maybe we're just
talking maybe this is a small apartment
maybe the walls are thin maybe one or
both of them are uncomfortable knowing
that someone's in the next room I don't
know let's just assume that's the
situation that we're in right now then
because the easy answer is what is what
you suggested which is what I do which
is like I don't worry about it you know
turn the music up and put the kids to
bed whatever it takes but let's assume
that's not
option you got to have a system well and
I think it's on your it you know this is
not like accommodating your guests I
think this is a scenario where they have
to accommodate you're hurting the
permanent guests have to be sympathetic
to hey they're on your turf and you know
they're in your territory and you know
you're not you can't apologize for
marking your territory mm-hmm you know
what I'm saying yeah and I say you gotta
you gotta have a way to communicate very
clearly now first of all you could just
say like tonight's the night but it
doesn't always happen like that you
don't you don't I just think we got to
have a system of like flags or something
you know like red flags on the door you
know like a torch burning out front
don't even come in the house yeah yeah
well I think it's a two flags this was a
three flag system
you got a flag that's on the outside of
the the door outside he sits in the
hallway of the apartment building or on
the front porch or whatever and that's
the styles are happening right now
do not enter because we could be in any
room you know the deaths of one system
this is where on the porch this is
outside I think that's a torch but go
ahead okay it's a torch flags or night
flags or say night purposes it's a
glow-in-the-dark flag perfect we can do
that perfect and then you've got a flag
system on the door of your bedroom the
bedroom the room where the Stiles
happened and and that's just a you the
flag is waving and that person just
needs to know I need it because if
you're the person in next room they're
not because it sounds like that's the
situation cuz nothing then I hope you
had a really good reason to let them
stay at your house I mean I'm just gonna
say that oh you should just kick them
out I'm saying if you you know if you
knew this is gonna be a I just hope that
you have a you know if this is permanent
first of all if this is permanent you
got to figure this out quick where's the
third flag you said that was a third
flag yeah there's two flags on the
bedroom door depending on what you're
doing
Oh
okay you told my how many flags you need
to purchase now how many locations are
four flags yeah I really like how long
this is going to be we got like a we got
like a we got like the seven-minute flag
like we'll be out there and watch TV
with y'all on a second
that's one flag so they so so they know
I don't have to leave the house I could
just go on a walk take a smoke break and
I'll be back and everything will be cool
and then you got another flag which is
like I need to go to Applebee's you know
what I'm saying
dinner in a movie situation I got a
leave for an extended period of time
you never know what kind of night it's
gonna be it might be a seven minute
night or it might be like a other okay
dude a 13 minute night you know
somewhere between 7 and 13 minutes I
mean even if this is if this is feeling
awkward for you then that's your problem
because this is its natural this is
human this is how we all got here well
via flags that flex we should sell that
kit oh man look at the mark-up on that
would be incredible three flags when I
was glow-in-the-dark we could probably
make that get that made overseas do you
think there's that much of a demand for
less than a dollar for the totally a
close quarter roommate situation I don't
know but if we sell it I mean it's worth
so much to people we sell it for $75 you
just put the right picture on it saw it
for $75 weeds to sell a hundred of them
we're doing great have we helped you
have we have we I think we have boy have
we made things awkward if we made things
worse I don't know but you can let us
know hashtag ear biscuits and we've got
you know there's questions that we
didn't get to so we'll try to get to
these romantic just pinning depending on
what you thought about how we did we may
answer more questions if the flag system
really just that turns you off
completely
they will never talk about this again
I'm still
thinking about it though I just feel for
those people that that's the situation
they're in I feel for a lot of people I
feel like in in in closing I just feel
very fortunate that you know as young as
we were that we found the soulmates
I do believe that we that I have a
soulmate and you know what
she is my soulmate and then for us we
were in this system where we had kids
young and now we're at this place where
it's weird to have had kids as young as
we have but we still have so much of we
still been able to pursue our careers
mostly pinpointed to the sacrifice that
Kristi and Jesse made to allow that so
that we can have our cake and eat it too
to have families career and a loving
committed relationship with our wives
that I know that you know to make it
this far is is when you say luck I think
what you mean by that is that it's it's
not because we're awesome people and
because we had all this amazing
foresight and made these informed
decisions like with like some sort of
magical knowledge of our compatibility
we can't you sure we can't take credit
for it so I just feel extremely grateful
that we're in this position that a lot
of people don't find themselves in and
and they're left dealing with that or
trying to figure it out so I don't know
if that puts a puts an encouraging spin
you know I I would I would like to find
a way to give hope to those people who
are listening who they're they just
don't have that love in their life that
they're wanting but I don't know what to
say beyond I
I hope you find it and you know I'm
sorry I don't I don't have them I don't
have a magical thing to say but our
hearts go out to you and we we don't
take credit for where we for where we
are I'll leave it at that
I agree with all that and the only thing
I have to add is who will speak at you
next week and we love you
[Music]